the main issue that people worry about
so far is that
sex robots will inspire people to have
strongly objectifying attitudes towards
sex partners to sort of make their
empathy go away because there's
literally no mind or subjectivity there
on the other side
for you to be sensitive to and so one
worry would be that one keeps
interacting with this robot
and then stops caring about the feelings
of the other whether they consent to
what you're doing and then that you
would carry over that behavior to a
human
why is the relationship between humans
and robots
interesting oh okay um
well it's interesting for a bunch of
different reasons i mean one reason is
that
people are in a certain sense not well
prepared to
deal with or respond to robots because
our brains our psychology
developed before we had any robots
before we had any ai
uh i mean it developed during human
evolution for
hundreds of thousands of years and then
suddenly we have this
enormous jump in technological
development and now we have we have
robots we have ai we have all sorts of
uh interesting technology and but we're
responding to it
with the brains the human psychology
that developed during this long time
so that sometimes means that we respond
to
things that look or act like humans
which some robots do
sometimes in humorous ways sometimes in
ways that might be dangerous for us
uh but very often in fascinating ways
and so that's that's one good reason i
think to
think about the relationship between
humans and robots so our
current mental makeup is unsuited to
interacting with robots that's the basic
sort of foundation yeah i mean so we're
basically primed to
anything that moves seemingly on its own
accord uh
in this apparently intelligent way uh
our brains will think
okay this is a this is some sort of
agent uh it's an animal it's a person
and uh our sort of human social
attitudes are triggered i mean this can
happen at the same time as we're
thinking to ourselves you know it's just
a robot it's just a machine
it doesn't have any feelings uh doesn't
like me or dislike me
but nevertheless emotionally we respond
to the entity as if it's
you know another person i mean not all
all of the time but uh
i mean the interesting thing is that
this is not just true of laypeople but
also experts
they talk about robots as if they have a
mind
as if they have desires beliefs
and people will say about a self-driving
car for example i i'm thinking of a
self-driving car as a kind of robot
that it wants to go left or right it has
to decide what to do
so we have this tendency to
anthropomorphize as people say i mean so
attribute human-like qualities to robots
two technologies
i mean you you hear people even before
robots
people would describe you know your
dad's car
or your mum's car and they'd say oh
she's she's a little bit cold this
morning it might take a little bit of
time to start her up like we
we personify inanimate objects in that
way don't we
everything thomas the tank engine has a
face
he's a tank engine with a face he
doesn't need a face he's a tank engine
but lest we decide to do it
yeah i mean the fakes that makes makes a
difference i mean just put two
pair of eyes on something and then
people will feel like they're being
watched
and uh you know uh if that thing with
the pair of eyes can also move
in a functionally autonomous way uh can
behave
in a way that seems intelligent to us
then again you're gonna have all your
sort of responses that have been
programmed into you by evolution over
thousands hundreds of thousands of years
they're gonna be triggered even if you
think to yourself okay it's a robot
someone painted eyes on it they wanted
me to respond in this way
but you can't help it and as i said it's
not just uh it's not just laypeople it's
experts too
i mean one of my colleagues uh joanna
bryson who argues that
i mean in her way of putting it robots
should be slaves
uh meaning that you know there are
things that we can buy and that we
can own and they're created to be uh
you know useful for us uh and so
what you shouldn't treat any person like
this because that would be a slave
however uh in the case of a robot i mean
you have this on the one hand you're
responding to it
uh as if it's a person but uh you know
it's something that you buy in soldier
it's been created for human
uh use uh and so i mean what she's
arguing is that we should
design robots in such a way that we
don't have these responses
the problem of course being that a robot
doesn't have to look like a human it
doesn't have to look like an animal
i mean there are there's interesting
stories about
military robots but they look some of
them look like
i don't know vacuum cleaners or uh lawn
mowers
uh but you know they they're part of the
the team uh the soldiers become attached
to them
uh there was one robot that uh helped to
you know find in uh bombs in the
battlefield
and of course eventually it you know i
got blown up by a landmine or something
like that
uh the soldiers wanted to fix that
particular robot they didn't want a
replacement not even a better one
uh eventually it was destroyed beyond
repair and then
they gave it to a military funeral they
wanted to give it medals of honor
etc so you can get very attached to a
robot
even though it doesn't look like a
person like a human i mean that robot
didn't even act like an animal or a
human but nevertheless they got really
attached to it so
it's it's fascinating didn't
we two other examples from your book one
is
a robot got to meet the queen of denmark
and then another one was given honorary
citizenship in
china or south africa or something yeah
so the examples are right
the country is wrong so the the one that
got to meet the queen that was uh
here in the netherlands where i am uh so
this was a robot uh
called amigo uh who is uh or what which
is i should
perhaps say it's an it uh it's a medical
care robot uh again this doesn't look
like a person i mean
it does have a head and it has her arms
and so
um the former university i worked for
was developing this robot is when the
queen came to visit
uh this robot uh gave the queen
a bouquet of flowers and and asked the
queens what's your name and the queen
sort of
immediately responded by accepting the
flowers and saying her name
uh and uh i mean none of the students at
the university got to meet the queen
only this robot and
yeah the other one was sophia
the robot and the country was saudi
arabia
and so this i mean this has been quite
controversial so
uh this is a robot that unlike the other
one that i just mentioned
it does look like a human so it has a
very human-like face
the back of the head of the robot is
transparent so that you can see the
electronics in there
the idea is that no one should be fooled
that this is a robot but this is one
where people
really respond in anthropomorphizing
ways
so this one has you know appeared in
front of political bodies the un
uh the munich security council uh the
british
parliament i think and um has appeared
on the tonight show with
jimmy fallon took a selfie with angela
merkel the
chancellor of germany and uh yeah i mean
why exactly well maybe it's the novelty
it's a
humanoid robot uh but um
but yeah it's been controversial it's
very fascinating example of people
reacting in these ways
there's a couple of terms that you've
used so far talking about it being an
agent it having agency what are the
premises that we need to understand
before we can get into this conversation
about robot human ethics
yeah yeah okay so those are some
technical terms indeed so
uh agency is something that philosophers
such as myself that we
we love to talk about it all the time i
mean of course one problem is that
others
such as software developers and uh i
mean
people developing medicine some
sometimes to talk about what's the
active
agent uh ring reach and so on so it
on the most general level an agent is
something that can
act or react to the environment
in a more or less predictable
intelligent seeming
interesting way of course there can then
be
different kinds of agents and so um
i mean a very simple i don't know insect
is a sort of agent because it interacts
with the environment in a goal-directed
way
uh but it's it can't you know i don't
know have a conversation
uh whereas you know you and i are agents
that can have a conversation such as
this one
uh you know you do something and uh so
let's say i don't
agree with it i might try to hold you
responsible you might
defend yourself uh thereby exercising a
much more advanced form of agent and an
insect
you know that maybe bites you doesn't
you know you might just
i don't know just kill it and
immediately don't think that it deserves
any kind of
uh chance to or opportunity to sort of
explain itself
i mean in the class of human agents you
have anything from
infants i mean they can't really do
anything i mean but they're
they're learning over time they become
more and more advanced agents
and so uh one question then that arises
is
could a robot be some some form of agent
um
i mean okay before we get too into it
too much but that's the idea of agency
like the ability to
uh sort of interact with the environment
in a goal-directed way perhaps being
able to
talk or converse with other agents
perhaps being able to take
responsibility for what one is doing
being able to make decisions make plans
and so on and so forth what other are
there any other words
that we might encounter over the next 50
minutes or so that need defining before
we get into it
yeah i mean i already mentioned the word
uh anthropomorphized to anthropomorphize
something is to attribute sort of
human-like equalities to it
uh we kind of already explained that but
that's a key word
i mean maybe we should say something
about what a robot is
i mean obviously it's a everyday term
and as it happens
it was introduced uh this the term robot
100 years ago
uh in a play uh so this is a term unlike
artificial intelligence that was that
is a term that scientists came up with
robot uh
is a word that comes from a czech word
uh
and i'm not gonna attempt to pronounce
the czech word but
it's a czech word that's been sort of
changed into a noun
uh it was a verb meaning i don't know
to perform forced labor or something
like that
uh and then uh turn into a noun in a
play
about robots about artificial human
beings that are
created to serve humans that's the
origin of the term
i think these days uh i mean when we
think of the term robot we think of a
maybe like a metallic
human like shape that would be the
paradigmatic robot
but if however we look at sort of real
world robots that are useful to anyone
that people actually
are interested in in terms of buying and
selling them
it would be maybe something like a
roomba vacuum cleaner
robot a self-driving car i mean
that's very hyped uh robot
um on so a lot of these functional
robots i mean robots in logistics
warehouses moving boxes around
they don't look like humans they don't
look like the paradigmatic robot out of
science fiction like c3po and star wars
uh so those are two different kinds i
mean
the silvery metallic one the ones from
real life that look like boxes with arms
etc
and then there's robots such as sofia
that the one that we already talked
about uh
i mean made to look like a human made to
act like a human
uh like whatever what do all these
things have in common you might ask
uh well okay so here people that work on
this sometimes they don't even want to
give a definition because there's so
many things that we
mean when we talk about robots but if
one
word sort of speaks forced to give a
definition people sometimes say
something like
it's a machine with some degree of
artificial intelligence
that has some when that
of course is already a technical term
that also has some functional autonomy
another technical term that means that
the machine can operate on its own for
some period of time
without direct human interventions uh
and uh so it's basically a machine that
can do something
that seems to be intelligent that's
often what people
i mean by robots i mean sometimes people
talk about what they call the let's see
if i can remember the
the sense plan act definition of robots
it can sense the environment
it can plan a response and then it can
carry out that response take action
that's another definition people
sometimes use but
i mean from my point of view i think
it's better to just talk about different
examples of things that people call
robots
and then ask i mean for example do they
have agency of some
interesting sort do people
anthropomorphize them is that
good is it bad and so on yeah um i mean
even if we roll the clock forward
nanotechnology probably over the next
hundred years is going to be big and
what do people say
tiny little robots that's what they
that's what they call them right so
yeah from from the grand scale to the
smallest those are
the the definition and the boundaries of
what it means is uh
is going to continue to get blurred so
you lay out an argument
quite early on in the opening chapter
your argument would you be able to take
us through that
yeah so this goes back a little bit to
what we were talking about
early on about how people respond to
robots uh again
we are um we are equipped with a brain
and a mind that
you know developed over hundreds of
thousands of years uh that's sort of
a multi-purpose uh organ or
capacity that we have uh that to some
extent
has has prepared us to build robots i
mean we we're creating
ourselves but it doesn't necessarily
prepare us to respond well to robots
and sometimes we will
become maybe too attached to robots we
will trust them too much
uh one part of our mind will say it's
just a machine
you know it can't it's not intelligent
whereas the emotional part of our minds
will get attached to the robot will
trust it too much uh
and we will build you know technologies
that you know have
robotic and other elements that will you
know polarize us online etc
we have all these problematic responses
to technology
i mean online polarization that's that's
that's one thing it doesn't have too
much to do with robots but
that's just another example of how we
react in
sometimes funny sometimes dangerous
sometimes not very nice ways to the
technologies that we have
and so we face the kind of choice i
argue
either we try to change the technologies
so that they are better sort of suited
uh for us with our human nature and
typically that's that's the right
response because you know why should we
change ourselves to sort of make
ourselves more adaptive to technologies
but in some cases it may actually be
worth also asking
should we somehow try to change the way
that we behave
and the way that we think so that we are
better adapted to interact with
technology such as
robots and ai i mean for our sake i mean
maybe in the future for the sake of the
robots if they get intelligent enough i
mean some people
already talk about the idea of maybe
robots should have some sort of rights
if they're intelligent enough
uh if they awaken sort of social
responses in people
so the idea is that for our sake we have
to do something
because we are exposing ourselves to so
many risks when we are creating these
technologies
and then two of the most obvious things
we can do is to try to change the robots
to make them better adapted to us or
somehow train
try to change ourselves to make
ourselves better able to interact with
robots but we
in order to avoid the risks we are
creating for ourselves we have to do
something or other and so i'm kind of
exploring
both options uh in in this book that
we're talking about
uh you know sometimes
as i said the most obvious thing is to
change the technology so it's better
suited for humans but that might also
make us
miss out on some of the benefits that we
want uh and i don't know if we want to
jump into any particular examples at
this point yeah yeah yeah yeah throw
some uh i mean one that i spent quite a
bit of time on and we already mentioned
this
is the self-driving car uh so this is
uh you know why do we want or need
self-driving cars uh the typical answer
is that
people are not super good at driving we
drive sort of well enough
that we don't you know crash most of the
time
but a lot of the time we do crash it's
very dangerous we're also driving in
energy not inefficient ways we're using
up much more resources than we
uh you know need to because we you know
we're accelerating in a kind of quick
way and not breaking gently etc
so one can envision a more ideal and
more optimal form of driving
and that's where the self-driving car
comes in it's supposed to be
you know a car that's better at driving
than a human drives in a more
environmentally
uh friendly way killing few fewer people
along the along the way so to speak
uh and so it's a more optimal type of
driving agent if you will to use the
terminology again now the problem is
that if you have self-driving cars
and human-driven cars on the road at the
same time
you get a kind of coordination problem
because humans
expect uh cars self-driving cars to
behave like human-driven cars
and so there have been a lot of i mean
mostly minor crashes that what typically
happens is that people drive
into self-driving cars because they
think that they are going to be
accelerating
more quickly drive more aggressively but
the average self-driving car today sort
of programmed to follow the rules like
to the letter so to speak like never
speed never drive aggressively etc but
humans
do all of those things and then some
people have suggested i mean i went to
one
conference with people advising the
dutch government about how to develop
our sort of
self-driving cars research program here
in the netherlands uh some
one person said well we need to adjust
the self-driving cars so that they drive
like
human drivers do so they need to
inherit our bad driving habits at speed
they should drive aggressively etc but
i mean then in a way that you you would
take away all this
you know the the benefits that are
supposed to be there with self-driving
cars and there's they should
drive less aggressively keep you know
follow the traffic rules
and not you know a drive like humans and
so
this seems to be one of those cases
where you do have an interesting choice
should we try like if we want to drive
at the same time as this also
self-driving cars on the road should we
adapt ourselves and our driving to this
robotic
cars self-driving cars or should we make
them
adjust themselves to us i mean probably
the best answer is some some sort of
compromise where both are adjusted to
each other but on the other hand
uh it does seem that it would be good if
we drove in a more safe way
of course people differ a lot in how
much so some people say you know within
five years we're going to have
fully automated super safe cars and you
know it's going to save
you know thousands of hundreds of
thousands of lives that are killed by
human drivers
every year others say well actually it's
it's really quite hard to develop a
fully self-driving car
that would work in all kind of traffic
conditions uh
in all weathers uh who that are able to
you know
interact with all kinds of environments
anything crazy that people do on the
road
so the expert different how safe they're
gonna be but if we do
accept the premise that eventually they
are going to be safer than humans
uh then it would be strange in a way to
say well let's make them drive like
humans so that we can
you know have them adjust themselves to
us so that
it seems to me to be one case where we
might wanna
investigate are there ways in which we
can make humans
drive more like robots i'll tell you an
interesting
example that i remember hearing last
year on a podcast
someone was talking about the
social habits that were being learned
from people using voice control on
devices like alexa and siri
and they were saying that young children
there was a fear that young children and
older adults
would begin becoming less polite and
using fewer social norms when talking to
people
because you don't say hey siri
please turn on the light you say hey
siri turn on the light um
and when you then port that behavior
back across
into the social world into the human
world you actually end up with it being
very misaligned
yeah so i mean that's just one example
of many
where people worry about uh the robots
would sort of
inspire certain behavior on the part of
the humans interacting with them and
then that behavior then sort of carry
over to the
to humans and uh i mean another example
which we might talk about
would be the sex robot there
one of the biggest criticisms that have
been raised against them from a sort of
feminist point of view is that
well people will start treating sex
robots made to look like humans
in a very objectifying way in a rude way
you know
not at all the sort of nice way that we
would like
sex partners to treat each other and
then that attitude will be
carried over to uh humans even more than
it is today so that people will
objectify each other even more than
they're already doing
uh so that's i mean that's a different
example than the the
alexa or siri whatever but it's the same
same sort of argument that
we will learn a certain behavior by
interacting with
these robots or robotic or other
technologies and then
that behavior will sort of carry over
into our interaction with human beings
if a self-driving car kills someone
who's responsible
uh yes that is another topic that uh in
terms of i mean
actually here too we have a bit of a
technical term responsibility
uh of course it's an everyday term we
hold each other responsible we ask who's
responsible
but uh we sometimes don't know exactly
what we mean
or at least we don't know what the
conditions are that we
sort of that lead our intuitions or to
guide our intuition intuitive judgments
about these things
uh a lot of philosophers say if i'm to
be held responsible for something
uh i first have to be able to predict
what's going to happen when i
act i have to understand my environment
you know what i'm doing
uh if i don't you know if i don't know
what i'm doing and i don't know what's
going to happen then in a way i have an
excuse to
for not doing the right thing so that's
sort of one condition another condition
is i should be able to control
uh you know what i'm doing if i lose
control
someone puts you know i come in there i
put some sort of drug in your drink that
you have there
and you sort of go crazy and start doing
strange things
uh you know you can say that you know
you lost control over yourself because
you were drugged or something like that
so
you should be able to predict to know
and understand your what you're doing
and you should be able to have some
control over it
that makes you responsible now if i
am using a self-driving car uh and i
am not a very technical person let's say
i don't really know how it works
uh i mean i can say please take me to
the grocery store and as the car is
doing that it's you know hits and kills
someone
am i responsible well i didn't really
understand what was going on
i maybe i i had no direct control of it
because i mean i
i maybe i said okay take me to the
grocery store but then
everything that happened was you know
done by the you know the computers
in the car the artificial intelligence
the you know whatever
technologies are involved so it would be
strange to say that i am responsible
for what happened now there are
complications of course
let's say that i'm the owner of the car
uh and i maybe signed a contract saying
that if something bad happens then
i should be responsible actually tesla
they have may not they don't have fully
self-driving cars but they have
something
that's called autopilot which is sort of
a certain form of automation
and so they do have a contract with
their customers and users of this
automation that if you engage the
autopilot
then you are responsible tesla does not
take responsibility for
anything that happens so this is this is
one way of solving the problem we just
make a contract
a lot of people have responded to this
particular type of example by saying
like well actually tesla built the car
they say it's safe
and they are benefiting a lot from
having people buy and you know
actually it's pretty expensive to get
this upgrade to the autopilot feature
so since they are benefiting maybe they
should be held responsible so that's
another kind of answer
the first answer was you know whoever
signed a contract agreeing to take
responsibility the
another answer would be who benefits the
most from the
existence of this technology maybe maybe
tesla in this case
uh another kind of answer that maybe
um possibly would seem more fair i mean
of course
this thing's my old alliance maybe i
sign a contract and i benefit the most
but you could also ask you know who has
the ability to sort of
update the technology to to monitor
and monitor it and see what it's doing
uh to maybe
stop using it if it turns out that it's
not very you know useful to begin with
and you know you can create kind of a
checklist and uh
the well the problem is that sometimes
maybe one person can update it another
is monitoring what it's actually doing
a third person is in charge of stopping
the the program of you know using this
technology so to speak
so we do get what is sometimes called
responsibility gaps
uh that means that there's a sort of you
know it's a feeling or a sense and
intuition that someone should be held
responsible
but a lot of the conditions that we
typically think that should
should be fulfilled in order for someone
to be responsible i mean whether it's
control whether it's knowledge whether
it's there's a contract etc
either they're not fulfilled or
different people sort of live up to this
criteria
and so that's that's a bit of a
problem yeah it's so interesting um
i went on to the mit website
that ethics uh the car trolley problem
thing the yeah the moral machine website
yeah that's it so
anyone that wants to feel uncomfortable
for 10 minutes go on
just google the moral machine and an mit
website will come up and you do a
little quiz and you go left you choose
left or right you basically choose who
you want to kill
and um you just consistently
don't know what the best option is for
that
do you have any sense of why people are
so uncomfortable around autonomous cars
even if in the aggregate they would save
lives
okay yeah good question so yeah let's
let's say that uh
they save thousands of lives every year
but they will kill a few people because
any
technology will you know stop working
sometimes
uh you know there will be some the tree
falling over and
like you can't have any technology
that's moving fast and it's heavy
and that it's 100 safe it's not
impossible so they
they will sometimes kill people uh but
as you said we can assume that they
would just
save a lot of lives and so on aggregate
they might be doing better than human
drivers
even so the idea of being killed by
a machine seems worse to people than
being killed by a human
of course it's not nice to be killed by
a human however
we also have another impulse so i talked
about we want to hold people responsible
another sort of intuitive impulse or
feeling that we have is that we want to
punish
and of course this goes back to what i
talked about before you know our brains
developed over long periods of time and
we
developed these sort of attitudes and
emotional reactions that we have
and uh whenever someone is harmed
uh and it seems that could have been
avoided
we tend to want to find someone to blame
and punish
and you know you you maybe you could say
i mean i actually have a colleague who
says let's
punish the self-driving car let's play
in the car
but to the average person this is not a
very satisfying idea because
uh well another colleague of mine rob
sparrow he argues that
well if you punish someone you call
suffering to them to some extent you
make it
life hard for them but a car a
robot they can't suffer so you can't
punish them
in the way that you would you know want
to hold someone accountable in the sense
of you know giving them a hard time
uh i mean some people then come back and
say well that's that's one
function of punishment to sort of make
the
the bad people suffer another function
of punishment is to sort of indicate to
other people
what not to do to deter them and
maybe if i punish a self-driving car i
could maybe deter
other people from acting like the
self-driving car but it i mean it
doesn't seem very
uh plausible i mean maybe you could
deter other companies from developing
cars that would behave in that way
uh yeah but uh so
we again have this problem that you know
who who are going to punish who we're
going to blame
we want to blame someone we want to hold
someone responsible we want to punish
someone
uh i mean you might say actually these
are not very nice
impulses that people have uh this fact
that we have this sort of deep-seated
desire to punish people who cause harm
maybe it would actually be better to
to try to remove that from our nature
and i mean i have
other colleagues again people you know
we philosophy we like to explore
different options and so we always have
sort of someone
working in the job of you know you go
and investigate whether we can
that would be a good idea and so one of
my friends argues that well actually we
should try to
take out this uh retributivist intuition
so
we want to punish that would be better
uh i mean i guess
my response would be that perhaps it
would be better but also good luck i
mean that's it's not so easy because
it's very deeply ingrained
into our nature so i mean i don't even
know where you where you would begin
uh some people would say well we do find
that
some of the uh medicines and drugs we
take for other
things they sometimes change our
emotions and our responses
i mean i believe that you talked with a
friend of mine brian arp he
is interested in exactly this topic and
uh
one of the things that got brian uh
interested in whether we can actually
use
drugs to sort of control people's love
lives and emotional
lives is that it's been noticed that
drugs for other things such as
depression
uh etc they sometimes affect our
feelings and our
attitudes how trusting we are of others
and well maybe if we discover some sort
of side effects of some drugs that would
make us less
willing to punish or eager to punish
people maybe we can use that
yeah after someone has a crash with a
self-driving car or is killed by a
military robot or something like that
to sort of um to think about this you
know what happened in a way that doesn't
involve
wanting to find someone to punish could
be could be one way of going i don't
know
tesla's gonna have to supply you with
some supplements uh an annual
supply of of tablets so that you can do
that as well you saw right the
um the whole principle for
why we have friendship and what it means
to have rivals and
what it means to have uh reciprocal
altruism and kin selection and all of
these
it is it's the foundation of what makes
us human that social element right
and uh yeah yeah to deprogram that i
think you're asking an awful lot
but on the flip side there is something
that feels awfully unfair
i mean it's unfair to be run over by
anybody but it feels
oddly unfair to be run over by a car but
that being said i
imagine that when cars first came out in
the sort of early 1900s
there would have been complaints around
well they're moving so quickly look at
how many people they're gonna kill
horses would have been a much better
solution we the horses on the road yeah
they make a mess and
but they go slower there's gonna be
fewer accidents you wanna put these cars
on the road that's gonna cause more
accidents
or before the tube and the london
underground were made it's like well you
know if we
if we allow people to get on the tubes
some people are going to fall in front
of the tube and they're going to get
killed they're not going to get killed
when they're walking on the street
especially if there's only horses and
carts upstairs
so i wonder how much of it is a status
quo bias
that's just simply people feeling
uncomfortable
getting out of inertia and interchange i
feel like that probably is a lot we're
pretty
the reason that we're so good as a
species is that we're adaptive right
and we are incredibly quick at adapting
so when the new thing happens
we'll probably end up adapting to it the
beauty or the challenge i suppose that
we have at the moment is that we can
step into this programming
globally the um technological
programming the societal programming the
cognitive programming
we can say okay we have the opportunity
to choose what sort of a direction we
would like to go down
right now before we actually get there
and we just adapt to whatever the hell's
going on
we can make the choice of the direction
that we think would be optimal
yeah i mean i do think that there's a
bit of a development in this direction i
mean so
typically what has happened in the past
is that technologies are developed put
out into society and then you know later
problems are fixed
but yeah but then at that
point in time i mean it's typically hard
to fix things because you know
technologies they're getting ingrained
into everyday life and they sort of
almost recede into the background and we
we don't even think of them as
technologies anymore we just think of
them as you know part of everyday life
so
even what we what's also called a
technology
you know or a robot or artificial
intelligence tends to be something
that's
new and a bit unfamiliar uh
and uh but once it's you know taking on
that sort of
part of our sort of human landscape of
like the world we move in
then it can be pretty hard to change it
because i mean just think of cars i mean
uh our cities are now you know totally
planned you know
for you know where people have to park
where they drive etc and
where you can walk and you cannot walk i
mean that's changed over time and so if
actually if you look at
old pictures of you know when the cars
and roads
was first came into the cities i mean
people were walking everywhere
biking random directions on the road i'm
actually where i live in the netherlands
they still do but still i mean things
change over time but then it gets
ingrained uh
and part of this or just the backdrop of
our lives and it's very hard to change
i do see more uh development now that
there's so much discussion about
uh risks and fears related to ai and
robots and things like that so
there's there's a move towards trying to
put the ethical reflection into the
design process itself
i mean that's part of the reason why mit
has that website with the moral machine
uh they're trying to find out people's
attitudes about self-driving cars before
we have a lot of them everywhere
i mean some people have responded that
well you know the self-driving cars i'm
not going to be choosing between killing
two grandmothers or one grandfather and
and two dogs
is you know that's the sort of dilemmas
that you get on that website that you
talked about before
uh they're gonna face very different
kinds of challenges for example
determining whether something is a
person or a branch or something like
that
and the the image recognition should be
good enough that
uh a self-driving car could tell if
something is i don't know like uh
just a shape that looks human from a
distance or whether it's actually a
human maybe it's some sort of heat
camera or something like that
so they need to know what their
environment is like and so
do they ever need to choose you know i'm
going to drive straight and run over two
grandmothers or goes
you know right and and you drive over
three i don't know granddaughters
or left and two grandfathers or
something like that i mean
that might happen every now and then not
not very often
uh but nevertheless it's all part of
this idea that we have to think about
these ethical issues
before we face them and we have to
somehow try to program
some sort of ethical uh i don't know
the compass if you will in into the
self-driving car or into the technology
that we're going to be using
it seems to me that you hit the nail on
the head there that technology tends to
move quicker than the legislation that
catches up with it governments are these
big lumbering behemoths that take
forever to do anything
uh whereas silicon valley can just get a
product out and see what happens we're
seeing that with
um phone addiction at the moment
everybody uses
their phone too much because the tactics
that are used by apps race to the bottom
of the brainstem and they're able to
manipulate you in ways that
perhaps if we'd known if we were
omnipotent and had known in advance we
would have said actually
let's not have that feature let's not
allow infinite scroll
let's not allow auto play not to let's
not allow bings and bongs and tick tock
generally but it's out there and now we
need to play catch up
um one of the things that makes me a
little bit more hopeful at least for the
self-driving car analogy
is that because the
outcomes are so grave and newsworthy i
think that a lot of the companies are
going to err on the side of caution
like you do not want to be the company
that's killed two people in the same
city in the same week
like you just don't because it's going
to be so bad for pr
but the um socialized
costs or the externalized costs should i
say
of the technology being wrong with
regards to self-driving cars is so
obvious and newsworthy compared with
the more slippy difficult to define
technologies like social media and stuff
like that like you don't really see
someone's mental health degrade or their
sense of self-worth get worse over the
over half a decade you know like it's
it's a lot harder to define and that
person themselves you know if you're
dead or a lot well you don't know if
you're dead you're just dead
but you know if you're they're alive
your family will know precisely but
whereas your family
perhaps don't know the arrow of
causation between
you spending too much time on tick tock
and you wasting your life
um so i wanted i wanted to talk i wanted
to talk about this for ages
are sex robots ethical okay yeah from
one thing to another uh
yeah uh i mean just real quick maybe
about that
case of self-driving cars killing people
and the company doesn't want to have you
killed two in a week i mean
it is interesting to compare it with
space travel
uh the first time that someone went to
the moon it was a world event like
everyone was in front of the tv watching
very
you know carefully the second time
smaller tv audience
the third and i i think i don't remember
remember how many times they've been to
the moon but i think it's maybe
less than less than ten i mean five
maybe something like that but
each time it was less of a thing uh and
now when people travel to space i mean
it's not even on the news i mean some
sometimes when tesla has a new rocket
that they're trying out that crashes
that's newsworthy i think it just
happened
today as we recorded this anyway but
the same thing could happen i fear with
self-driving cars crashing into and
killing people
normalized it's gonna be normal okay now
it happened again so
uh i mean i would agree with you that at
the moment it's you know world news when
it happens but
that's something that we're probably
gonna see the same sort of development
that it's gonna be normalized and so
they're gonna have more leeway
to sort of kill people so we just need
with all of this stuff we need to get
out ahead of it which is obviously why
people like yourself who essentially
just ask a million different
permutations of the same question
yeah that's why we require ethicists and
and that does take us back to the
question that you're really wanting to
discuss namely
are sex robots ethical or not because
this
is a good example of a question where i
mean there are
prototypes uh that are being created and
there are
sex dolls that have some uh features
that they can move a little bit and that
they have a sort of chat function so you
can talk with it in the way that you can
talk with siri or alexa that
like we mentioned before but certainly
the uh
sex robot that we maybe one imagine
someone thinks about that just that
concept like
something that's very intelligent
seeming that can really
you know behave in a very human-like way
doesn't really exist yet
however there are plenty of people
trying to develop them
uh and uh i mean is there a market uh
well
there's clearly a big enough market that
there are people are developing than
hoping to be able to sell all them so
there seems to be a an attempt to supply
and there seems to be
some some amount of demand but it's
they're not quite there yet
uh and so here we have another
opportunity to sort of start talking
about the ethical side of things
before it's a big big real world problem
and there again there are
already prototypes you uh
for some of them there's even discussion
whether it's a real company or sort of
or whether you can really buy them at
all or not i mean there's one
there's a website that's called
truecompanion.com
and they say on the website that you can
buy a sex robot called roxy
spelled with three x's uh that can be
as the website says a loving companion
that can
know your name get to know you uh have
orgasms
and and so on and so forth uh
i mean you i think you can put down sort
of a
you know make a payment and and order
one but uh
it's one of those things where it's very
hard to find people to say yeah i bought
one and i enjoy it and then
please go ahead and interview me about
my experiences with my sex robot so
uh but that's not to say that there
aren't people like that i mean uh there
is uh
one person that i discuss in my book and
that i'm almost become sort of friends
with uh yeah over time
who calls himself dave cat uh he lives
together with
not sex robots but but with a few sex
dolls
and he has done a lot of media
appearances uh
you know and all sorts of media on tv
podcasts etc
when he talks about how he lives
together with his sex dolls
uh and so there are people like that
that you can interview and talk about
you know their experiences with these
products but most mostly it's it's hard
to kind of
get uh beyond through anecdotes and uh
you know imagining what could happen and
so that that is what where we are and
like you said
ethics such as myself we're kind of
imagining all sorts of scenarios
and asking which you know seems best
from the point of view of values such as
consent uh objectification
uh will this make people
less good at interacting with human
partners etc etc
and like i said earlier
really the main issue that people worry
about so far is that
sex robots will sort of inspire people
to have
uh strongly objectifying attitudes
towards
sex partners to make to sort of make
their empathy
go away because there's literally no
mind
or subjectivity there on the other side
for you to be sensitive to
uh and so one worry would be that one
keeps interacting with this robot uh and
then
uh you know stops caring about
uh you know the feelings uh wheth
of the other uh whether they consent to
what you're doing
uh etc and then that you would sort of
carry over that behavior to a human
uh interestingly though i mean if you
take someone like
dave cat uh this person that i talk with
again i mean
if you look at the way that he talks
about his sex dolls
it seems to be very respectful uh he
says in one of the clips that i
i've watched with him when he's being
interviewed you know i wouldn't want to
treat
her as a sexual like a thing i won't
it's a person
uh so it's certainly it's possible on
the other hand
to have people who would and like we
said before people have these social
attitudes
towards robots you could ask then well
what if we could design sex robots in
such a way
that they would actually not trigger
sort of objectifying
bad attitudes but they would actually
kind of stimulate
train people to be maybe even become
better at interacting with other humans
uh you could imagine someone who feels
uh you know uncomfortable about their
you know performance in that domain and
that who wants to train themselves
maybe get to know human anatomy better
they're embarrassed about
doing that with another person but
perhaps a sex robot could serve as a
kind of
educational tool for them a sort of
teacher
uh i mean that's this is something that
uh others are also think thinking about
you know what
not only what are the bad possible
consequences and risks
but also what are the potential benefits
i mean take another case
uh let's say that you are someone is the
victim of sort of sexual assault or
rape or something like that and that
they feel
extremely uncomfortable around human sex
partners but they want to get back into
sort of the the sexual world so to speak
maybe
a robot uh that would you know do
whatever
they want i could be a way of becoming
comfortable again
with having sexual interactions with
other agents
and that could be a sort of stepping
stone towards like
returning to having sex with humans
that's a
that's one possible thing that people
say would make would be an argument in
favor of having them
another would be well let's say that
there's someone
who really can't find a sex partner
maybe
people around them they don't find them
attractive uh
they just have some sort of impossible
personality i don't know
so they really can't find a sex partner
but they still have a
deep longing to have sexual interactions
well maybe for them uh a sex robot would
be better than nothing
uh that would be that's another argument
that i've seen for why
sex robots would be ethical rather than
unethical and actually ethically
required that we should try to develop
them
so it certainly seems a bit something
that there are arguments on
both sides to me i struggle
i haven't found a compelling argument um
that says it's
unethical uh to use sex robots not
personally i just haven't been convinced
by any of them yet i understand that we
don't want to train people to go out
and behave in bad ways but those
externalized
uh sort of costs i i don't think that
they're going to happen
all that much i wouldn't be too
concerned about it and outside of that
i don't really see anything that's that
compelling to um
to stop it from happening however there
will be a lot of people listening who
may
disagree with me so i would be
interested to see in the comments below
what
what everybody what everybody thinks um
well i mean let me give you a case
that's maybe the the most difficult case
uh
hit me i'm excited yeah yeah well let's
see if you
stay excited so yeah sex robots are made
to look like children uh
that would be the case where a lot of
people feel
uh that that it crosses the line so they
might say okay if it's a sex robot that
looks like an
adult human being well a human being
that's another thing so
the two the two of the cases that people
have been concerned about
are ones that are made to look like i
don't know animals
a dog let's say or
especially i think i mean more serious
example is a sex robot
made to look like a child there too
though uh you have people who argue uh
not implausibly i would say that well
let's say that someone is a pedophile
and they they do recognize that it's
wrong
but they think that it's wrong to have
sex with children and yet
they can't control i mean they they
can't there's no conversion therapy
let's say
so the only physical outlet so to speak
would pay to have sex with either a
child
or a robot looking like a child maybe
it's ethically good if someone you know
takes the
goals for the robot rather than the the
human child
uh so it's been suggested it could be a
kind of therapy tool
um some would then say well nevertheless
there seems there's something sort of
inherently repugnant there's a sort of
moral taboo that we should respect
etc etc so this would be the case where
maybe
i don't know how you feel about that
case but then yeah oddly
i had this gonna sound so odd i had
a three hour conversation about the
ethics of sex robots
uh and at least half of it was talking
about this example as well
but it was on a plane out to dubai so
there was only one person that could
obviously
hear understand english in the in the
vicinity and this poor girl must have
been thinking what am i listening to
for the entirety of this journey um
my mind ever since i i was seeing a girl
at university who i was doing
medicine and was very very much into
medical ethics and she completely
changed my view
of how i saw pedophilia the difference
being between pedophilia
and child molestation and that's a
distinction that i think a lot of
sadly because the way that we use those
words they're used interchangeably but
they're not the same
um the first sort of thing to understand
was that
people do not control what they are
attracted to they have no conscious
control over that this has been shown in
fmris and also in arousal response you
show someone
every sexual situation under the sun
with not children
nothing happens you show them something
with children and everything happens
and the reverse happens too people can't
control what that happens okay
so what that means is that there are
some people who are brought into this
world cursed
knowing that their sexual proclivity is
they're disgusted by society no one
they're terrified to reach out for help
all of these sorts of things
now if it would appear that if we find
out that
upon bringing in sex robots the
externalities of someone using a sex
robot
seems to bleed that behavior out into
the real world
then we have quite a big problem if the
reverse happens
and it seems that by using the sex robot
we actually get a decrease
in that behavior out into the real world
and i don't know
what is more likely i'm not a
neurologist i'm not a behavioral
psychologist i don't understand sort of
what would tend to happen there
but you could actually imagine a world
in which you would reduce
human suffering by basically giving
someone
what is ostensibly a vibrator or some
sort of you know what's the difference
between
a is it an odd question to ask but
what's the difference between a very
small vibrator
and a small child sex toy
that would be used by a straight female
who had that sort of a proclivity
like really we're just getting back to
anthropomorphizing
we're bestowing some sense of agency
onto this being
especially if you're talking about a sex
doll which literally has
no inner workings at all
it's a fascinating like i i think about
this
far more than than i'd care to admit
because i just find it
i find the these things where the um
the precipice on both sides is
incredibly steep i enjoy thinking about
that because it makes me
be very rigorous with my thinking and i
hope that everyone that's listening kind
of feels the same this isn't here to
make us feel uncomfortable it's here
because it's an interesting and rigorous
discussion around something
which obviously has some pretty great
ethical implications
what's your opinion do you have a a
personal stance on this
uh well i mean and this is actually
something that i'm
thinking about at the moment and i'm
working together with a colleague on an
academic article about this
and so uh so i don't i don't have a
settled uh
opinion about it yet because we're
grappling with this issue i mean one
difference between the the child sex
robot and this small
sex toy that you were talking about that
doesn't look like a human
would be the symbolic difference in
terms of a one symbolizes uh you know
nothing maybe as the sex toy let's say
whereas the other symbolizes a child
and so depending on how much
uh importance one puts on symbolism one
might go different directions here so if
you think that
it's somehow disrespectful towards human
children to
you know create and buy and sell
a robot that looks like a child that
people want to have sex with
if you think that i mean that's enough
of a problem
you know out of respect for human
children you shouldn't
make money let's say off of this then
you might have a problem with this
uh however let's let's say that it's not
i mean it's it's some sort of therapy
tool that's created not
for profit and that it's you know highly
regulated or something like that
and so there's not sort of a commercial
market for it
then that symbol is an argument of sort
of making money off of this
maybe goes away a little bit uh and it
might become more acceptable
but i think this is one of the things
where you know you can imagine uh it
being more or less
unethical like let's say that you know
if you're you come up with this idea
i want to make money i'm going to start
creating and selling for
very you know big prices as child sex
robots
you do seem uh i mean not you but the
person who would have that idea
they do they seem at the very least
insensitive in their attitudes and
uh they seem to be open to moral
criticism but if someone however
had this idea that well maybe you can
save one or more
children from being molested by creating
a sort of therapy tool
that can be uh offered to uh you know
people with
pedophilia paleophilic uh desire so to
speak
uh in a sort of controlled setting well
then
uh you seem less open to this same sort
of criticism so
we had um during my discussion with
brian up
he was talking about people taking
people who are pedophiles taking ssris
to dampen down their libido um
the external effect that you get in both
situations
from that hopefully if we can roll the
clock forward and get the particular
therapeutic tool uh use out of a child
sex robot that we want
um the same externality occurs in both
situations that you have
less of a predation worry from this
particular subgroup
right the difference
that i can see is in one of them the
person actually
gets to proceed through life normally
and i know the people that listen to the
show are incredibly balanced and normal
but i know that there is that emotional
well you the the
freaks they should just be locked up
it's like oh like you're not as
you haven't seriously ethically thought
about this problem and you don't
understand
like empathetically what's going on um
i i wonder what happens when you scale
this sort of thing up to society wide
because inevitably the loudest voices
are the ones that that are heard
and some of those are going to be you
know
if you were a survivor of child sexual
abuse
finding out that child sex dolls
and maybe this one maybe this one looks
like you looked when you were
i mean we're getting into some very
uncomfortable
water as we get through there so yeah i
am
i wonder what again like let's take that
person
uh and if they know that this is done
for the sake of
not having if this happened to other
children and it's not done
to make big bucks you know like uh maybe
it becomes more acceptable to them but
nevertheless i mean of course they're
gonna be emotionally
you know going in different directions
because maybe on the one hand they think
that well
if it can have someone avoid having
happen to them what happened to me
that's good at the same time it might
seem
deeply offensive and it might seem as
some sort of acceptance and normalizing
of something that was really traumatic
and bad for them so
i can certainly imagine that's so
difficult money is going different
directions
so messy um you talk about robot rights
and we mentioned right at the top about
making robots
slaves should should we should we make
robot slaves
um yeah uh i mean some people have
responded to that
thesis by saying that we shouldn't use
we shouldn't use that terminology
because it brings up
uh ideas about uh you know
people making some others into their
slaves and that whole mentality is
is should go out the window and nothing
should be a slave
neither a robot nor person but i you
know in defense of my colleague jenna
bryson
she never meant to sort of and be
enthusiastic about this
past slavery or anything like that the
idea was just that
since people are going to be owning
buying and selling robots
and and i mean that's one feature of
slavery like you know you can buy and
sell
the slave and uh the slave is there to
be useful to
you to the owner the robots are gonna
have these properties and so
her suggestion was it's best to create
robots that wouldn't
uh be morally ambiguous for people so
that they wouldn't feel a sense of
responsibility so like
you make the robot look like a box you
know it doesn't have eyes
it doesn't sort of generate a sense of
responsibility
that's the best situation because then
we don't have to have these worries
about robot rights
however for some purposes
it might be more efficient to have a
robot that actually does
generate the social attitudes there is
one robot
that is being developed for treatment of
autistic children
and so the idea is that for some
children with autism they have trouble
engaging with other humans because they
find it overwhelming
so if you have a sort of a robot that
looks like a simplified human
this actually has in some experimental
studies
been shown to possibly work the the
child
sort of opens up and then even turns to
the experiment
and sort of points of the robot and say
like i look at this and that's already a
nice step forward
now for for that sort of therapy tool uh
you would need the robot to look a
little bit
human-like uh because yeah that's part
of the idea that it should look a little
bit like a human etc
now take that robot and then let's say
that after a day of experimentation
you know you take the robot to another
room and then you take out like i don't
know a baseball bat and start hitting it
or
you know yeah you uh you know do
something else to it that doesn't seem
to be sort of
very fitting that can seem i don't know
not again you if it's not
directly wrong it can seem like
insensitive let's say
uh you you know something that's been
developed for this purpose that they're
treating these children it should be
treated maybe in a more respectful sort
of way
uh is that to say that the the robot
should this therapy robot should have
some sort of rights
well uh it is to say rather that others
again out of respect for those
children that are being involved in this
treatment maybe
one should maybe treat the robot in a i
don't know
a dignified respectful way and then
again you can go to your example from
let's say that i have a robot that looks
like you
and then i mistreat that robot i mean in
a way that can seem as like some sort of
attack on you
so maybe again out of respect for you i
shouldn't either i don't make a robot
that looks like you perhaps the best
option
or if i do for whatever reason you know
there should be some maybe some limits
uh
how i treat this robot out of respect
for you uh
but this is still just a question of you
know how can we behave in a way that's
respectful towards other humans
the real question would be you know
would there be any circumstances where
out of respect to the robot you know you
should treat it well in some way
well i mean even today i saw on twitter
some
video about some scientists to the claim
that they have created robots that can
feel pain
uh there's another uh not the same team
i think and
the japanese team led by uh professor
asada i think is his name
uh who also tries to create robots that
can feel pleasure and pain because that
uh the idea is that they can learn in
the way that infants do that
you know before we learn language we
learn in an emotional sort of way
uh you know you might ask does it even
make sense to think that a machine a
robot could feel pleasure pain
if you believe that they are achieving
this
in their research and i myself am
skeptical then you do
get a interesting situation because
maybe the robot is not very intelligent
but it has
you know the capacity to feel something
in some sense or other
uh here too you might start thinking
like well
better be safe than sorry so let's not
cause too much unnecessary pain to this
robot
this of course depends uh it's dependent
on whether you think it makes any sense
to say that a machine could feel pain
yeah i think that's that's where the
sort of slippage is at the moment right
because inevitably you have
a reward function in most sorts of
circuits there is an outcome that you
want that's how
you know uh alphago zero worked that
there was an outcome it wanted and it
learned
essentially it was like if you've done
this then great this is the sort of
direction that we want you to go in
now if i just decide to recategorize
that as pleasure
and not that as pain okay but there is
no
phenomenological experience that it is
going through that the machine is going
through
which causes the suffering which causes
the
second order metacognition experience of
the suffering
itself to be able to say i mean to be
able to say as far as i'm concerned
whoever it is that's on twitter
we have created a robot which is able to
feel pain is to say we have created
consciousness
because i don't think that you can feel
pain without consciousness
any like a whack a rock with a stick
this the rock and the stick both
aren't in pain because neither of them
have consciousness
um yeah i'm
i'm unsure around that for me personally
i think that treating robots
as if they are just a scaled up version
of a macbook
makes the most sense at the moment now
giving them you talk about at the
beginning of the book giving them
citizenship and you slipped up at the
very very beginning of freudian slip to
say
uh who who is as opposed to it is
um and this gets into kind of i guess
the
the through thread that we're talking
about here just how misaligned we are
when we deal with any sort of robot and
the more that these robots can
look and act like humans the more and
more
our behavior is going to be modified
toward them that's going to have some
externalized consequences to our
interactions with other humans
there's also um concerns around whether
or not those robots themselves should
have
some sort of right some sort of sense of
anything else for me
i don't think that that really is a it
might be a concern to think about for
the future but
right now i don't think that it is um
but yeah it's going to be it must be for
yourself in this
industry right now it must feel like a
very interesting
and exciting place to be you know the
next sort of 20
years or so is we're going to see some
insane changes
yeah i mean part of this because as i
said there are scientists who claims
that
who are saying that they are creating
robots that can feel pleasure and pain i
mean i share your skepticism
about whether they have achieved that
goal but certainly there are people
at universities you know they're trying
to do this they claim that they can do
it
uh there are people developing sex
robots uh
self-driving cars all sorts of
interesting
and seemingly uh science fiction like uh
things but
you know people are actually doing it
and it's very clear that there are
interesting as
you know philosophical ethical questions
about it so yeah for people like me it's
great
sven thank you very much for today
humans and robots ethics agency and
anthropomorphism
will be linked in the show notes below
if people want to check out any more of
your stuff
where should they go uh well i already
mentioned twitter and i think that's uh
a good place i mean so i whenever i you
know do something like this
i appear on a podcast or i write a book
or an
article i always put it there so sort of
to advertise it so
that's a good place if people want to
know what i'm doing perfect yeah
it's just like it'll be linked in the
show notes below sven thank you so much
man
well thank you
[Music]
you